[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where
Hank green who is me and John green
who's my brother give you dubious advice
answer your questions and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon now it's true how are you Hank
I'm good
oh man hi my hair is out of control and
I can't find a time to get a haircut
it's a disaster John hmm I mean it's so
it's so hard to be me haven't you gotten
to a point in your life where you can
just call someone and have them cut your
hair while you work I had not thought of
that
I imagine that tell the president does
it that's exactly at the president
doesn't he's like on the phone with the
Prime Minister of the United Kingdom and
the Prime Minister is like I'm sorry
there's some background noise and he's
like I'm just getting a haircut
yeah I actually went to see the
president you may remember not to brag
or anything but I I was getting my
makeup done by his personal makeup
person and I asked her you know what is
it like to cut the president's hair and
she was like oh no no no no no no no no
I do not I do not cut the president say
he has a barber so it's two separate
peoples just oh yes 2e has two people he
has a hair person and a makeup yes and
the hair I also got the hair person
comes into the White House and cuts his
hair as far as I can the Oval Office so
apparently if you like just look at the
carpet at the oval office there's hairs
from every president III think they
haven't they have never replaced the
carpet it's amazing a nor nor have they
ever vacuumed it apparently um well I
mean since you brought up the fact that
you've met the president
Hank as we are recording this podcast I
am hours away from what could be the
most wonderful moment of my entire life
of course I have two beautiful children
I had a wonderful wedding day going to
your wedding was one of the highlights
of my life I've had so many great days
the premiere of The Fault in Our Stars
movie and the premiere of Paper Towns
both wonderful nights but tonight Hank
here in Indianapolis I have to tell you
Hank there's maybe eight or nine
properly beautiful days a year
it's usually a little too cold or a
little too hot or a lot
to cold or raining but today the sky is
a cloudless blue the temperature could
be no warmer or colder and and be more
beautiful it is just absolutely perfect
and do you want to know why Indianapolis
has chosen today to bring out its best
self yes John I do it's because Taylor
Swift is coming to town Taylor Swift is
here tonight and Hank III may meet her
Oh like you're going to a Taylor Swift
concert and you will and you will watch
her and yell Taylor and then and then I
mean I am going to go to a Taylor Swift
concert and watch her and yelled at by
all means but also I may meet her Wow
art is she gonna bring you up on stage
to sing a song with her I sincerely hope
not as my brother you are well aware
that when I am brought up on stage by
musicians to sing along I perform poorly
Hank always kindly has me come out for
the encores when I'm when we're doing
shows together and oh my god I'm just
the worst am I not not great at singing
it's okay it's kind of remarkable and
and the funny thing is you're always
like no it was I did the thing and I'm
like well you did the thing just didn't
sing any of the right notes and you
think you do it was just fine and like
it's it's fine to you know to not did
not have one of a million skills that
that humans are capable of having it's
just uh you know like all novelists I
desperately wish to be a rock star and
it is true that I can't sing but I do
genuinely believe that when we sung that
song New York City by they might be
giants at Carnegie Hall and I sung the
Statue of Liberty Staten Island Ferry
part I truly believed I was on key was I
not on key that night your silence your
silence has broken my heart yes you are
you are you are on key are you lying to
me is it okay for me to lie to you and
in certain circumstances just tell me
the truth just told you without your
handle it you aren't on key now it's
so that's devastating I can't believe
you told me that I specifically asked
you never to tell me that well tell me
tell me more about how you're going to
meet Taylor Swift are you gonna like be
backstage you're gonna get to like take
a selfie and like high-five and ask her
how she's doing Hank I do not know the
details but believe you me on next
week's dear John and Hank you will hear
about them you will hear about them in
excruciating detail I don't even know
for sure that I'm going to get to meet
Ms Swift but regardless I am going to
enjoy the concert because okay as you
know I'm a massive fan of 1989 both the
year and the pop album and I am just so
freaking excited I am I am over the moon
I would like to thank Taylor by the way
for for making room at her concert for
me in advance and not it not to hijack
the whole podcast but there is also
other news in my life that I would like
to share with home eyes good eye I have
gone on a social media hiatus I stopped
up the posting on the tumblers and the
Twitter's and the Facebook so the only
thing I'm really doing workwise
social media wise is vlogbrothers videos
on Tuesdays and then dear Hank and John
our comedy podcast and it's so that I
can write a novel and it's I'm only two
days in so far but I have to say it's
kind of great well I've identified a
problem with your two pieces of news
which is that you will meet Taylor Swift
and and not be able to do anything with
that you have to you have to you have to
snap that John it turns out that you
don't have to mediate experiences
through social media in order for them
to have really happened
that said I suspect that if if I do meet
Ms Swift but I I'm a I'm a and Instagram
that event but but we'll see life is
life is long and who knows but I'm
really enjoying my social media hiatus
because I have missed writing so much
it's been so long since I've had two or
three writing days in a row like the two
or three that I've had here and
obviously you need you know a couple
hundred of those to write a novel but
but yeah I'm feeling I'm I'm feeling
excited good well in in among your
social media hiatus I will say that I am
Hank GRE on
snapchat Hank green on Instagram Hank
green on Twitter and and and right here
at dear Hank and John on iTunes so if
you'd like to follow me I will not be
taking the social media hiatus oh and
Edward spoon hands on tumblr and and
I'll be just I'll be making all kinds of
interesting and and and and well
composed
filtered pictures of my dinner and don't
you want to see that follow me
it's nat chat I don't understand your
session with a snapchat you you really
seem to believe that snapchat is going
to be the thing that breaks you out of
your cult following into soccer
mainstream success that like you'll be
on the first of all night show or
whatever and and Jimmy Fallon or I I
literally don't know who hosts the
Tonight Show so I hope it's Jimmy Fallon
but whoever hosted tonight's show will
be like so Hank you know you had a big
following on the YouTube and of course
the big hit comedy podcast that was full
of ruminations about death and mars but
it wasn't really until your snapchat hit
it big that the world knew about you so
john the thing is that the only
following worth having is a cult
following because oh i could not agree
more yeah it's like the mainstream
success is just really unpleasant
so snapchat is very good at cultivating
that cult following and it's just it you
know it's just a couple tens of
thousands of people yeah it's just it's
a nice place now that you've explained
it that way i realized that i was
completely wrong and I apologize
speaking of which before we get to the
questions Hank we need to apologize to
our listeners who like Mario Kart
characters other than Luigi and Donkey
Kong there was there was a substantial
amount of controversy about to that also
we spent a lot of time talking about it
so let's spend a little more time
talking about people were tremendously
angry and hurt by the way that we
dismissed the likes of Yoshi
Princess Peach and even Bowser and I
would just like to State for the record
that you know I am a novelist Hank is
whatever Hank does like we are not
professional Mario car
players and I apologize for giving
advice as if I were an expert also as if
we were just to be clear talking about
Mario Kart circa n64 yeah I mean I was
talking about the Super Mario Kart that
I played on a yellow couch in 1994 when
there was no functional world-wide-web
so just remember that I grew up in a
different time I'm from a different era
Hank should we answer some people's
questions but John wait don't you have
to read us a poem so Hank you'll recall
last week short poem was by William
Carlos Williams who was a physician
often wrote very short poems on the back
of prescription pads this is just to say
I've eaten the plums that were in the
icebox etc mm-hmm well this is a
slightly longer poem that I really enjoy
it's by Kenneth Koch often associated
with the The Beat movement somewhat
unfairly I think but anyway moving on
it's a it's called variations on a theme
by William Carlos Williams I chopped
down the house that you had been saving
to live in next summer now I'm sorry but
it was morning and I had nothing to do
and it's wooden beams were so inviting
we laughed at the hollyhocks together
and then I sprayed them with lye forgive
me I simply do not know what I am doing
I gave away the money that you'd been
saving to live on for the next 10 years
the man who asked for it was shabby and
the firm March wind on the porch was so
juicy and cold last evening we went
dancing and I broke your leg forgive me
I was clumsy and I wanted you here in
the wards where I am the doctor
variations on a theme by William Carlos
Williams from Kenneth buck that poems
from 1962 and one of my absolute
favorites that's nice dad I like that I
knew I could find a poem you would like
if I tried hard enough I'm coming around
I'm coming around I don't know that
you're gonna slay me into becoming a
hardcore AFC Wimbledon fan but you may
yet make me enjoy poetry we have a
question John this question is from
anonymous who asks dear Hank and John I
have a very annoying housemate she
doesn't do her part of chores unless
someone tells her she doesn't have a job
so her parents
her rent but she still gets money from
the government and yet she can't pay her
bills on time she just sits around all
day watching TV or singing how can I get
her to do her jobs and pay her bills and
generally be a better housemate without
sounding like her mother when I asked
her to do these things oh goodness oh
goodness well we we've all well having
been that housemaid yes I feel like I'm
a bit of an expert in this so for many
years I lived with my best friend
Shannon James in the great city of
Chicago Shannon and I are still
extremely close friends in fact she's
visiting this weekend and I I was a very
messy person I mean I have I have
obsessive-compulsive disorder and so I
have like some weird compulsions that in
general make it difficult for to live
with me but um but also like I'm just
not a very clean person and for many
years I didn't recognize what messiness
was so I would be like sitting watching
TV or playing Super Mario Cart or
whatever and Shannon would be like is
there any way that you could pick up
around the house a little bit and I
would be like I would look around and I
would be like oh no everything's good
here what I don't even I don't know what
you're talking about and she would be
like well your pants are currently on
the coffee table and that's not ideal
and also there's there's 17 cans of wild
cherry Diet Pepsi on the living room
table as you might might notice and I
would be like oh that stuff and slowly
over the course of many years Shannon
trained me to have a better
understanding of what messiness is but
that was an act of extraordinary
generosity and love between two absolute
best friends this person doesn't sound
like your best friend you should just
kick her out yeah this person it's in
fact it sounds a little bit to me like
you sort of waver in this question
between being like this person needs we
need to like come to a better
understanding and insulting the person
which makes me feel like you have a bad
relationship with the person yeah I
would just go ahead and and sever the
house madness there's a bunch of people
out there looking for roommates yeah if
that's an option I mean the other thing
to remember
is that a lot of times what this what
this this activity comes from and I also
suffer from messiness blindness the way
that John does which is a struggle for
for Katherine and and she has also
lovingly trained me to understand what
what messy is but often times I had a
roommate that was a lot like this and it
turned out that he was you know
struggling a lot with depression and
that can be you know with like that's a
you know unemployment is a symptom of
depression you know not doing things is
a symptom of depression and and you know
not taking care of things that need to
be taken care of and so if you do want
to keep this person as a roommate or you
have to then the thing to do is to
create a great deal of structure and and
try and have that structure be the boss
and not you because one of the great
allies of of mental stability is
structure and and and if you can create
that and have it be something that this
person doesn't feel like they have an
option to avoid then they won't avoid it
they will do it and but that might mean
being a little bit of a mom or or
someone has to be the authority in that
case and and if it's the kind of thing
that this person is gonna be like you
can't be the boss of me then you know
maybe you find a different place where
they find a different place however
however it's set up whoever's the person
on the lease that makes that is gonna
have to make that call in the end yeah I
I agree with you I I kind of feel like
if you can't have open lines of
communication in a roommate relationship
it gets dark and walking on eggshells II
and passive-aggressive really really
fast yeah so you've got to just you've
got a what what Shannon and I would
always say because we had like other
roommates who would come and go and what
we would always say to the other
roommates is like in this house you must
be able to fight like you must be able
to fight lovingly and forgive each other
because if things are not like open and
honest around here then like it gets
super weird super fast
all right aye aye that's actually
something that we both have legitimate
experience with John do we have another
question yes we do and it's another
thing that we both have legitimate
experience with it's from Kathy she
writes dear John and Hank who do you
think would win in a fight
John's puffs or Patrick Rothfuss is beef
I mean John's puff is is amazing it's a
it's elegant it is some people call it
historically significant it is indeed
historically significant Patrick
Rothfuss is beard is also all of those
things and also much bigger than the
puffs and I would say you know
significantly more badass than the puffs
yep so I think that Patrick Rothfuss his
beard would win Patrick Rothfuss if you
don't know as the author of the name of
the wind an absolutely beautiful a
fantasy novel that's part of the series
that is that is in the middle of being
completed well he's a great writer it's
beautiful it's wonderful stuff it's it's
like you know if you like fantasy at all
it's basically in my opinion like the
thing that happened in in the you know
since 2010 that matters a lot I mean I
don't I don't know anything about
fantasy all I know is that like sentence
to sentence he is a beautiful beautiful
writer and I met him in real life at
VidCon this year and you know I'd seen
pictures and everything but meeting him
in real life is interesting because
almost immediately as soon as you start
talking to him you realize that his his
beard is bigger than he is and it's it
he's really the only person he's the
only person I've ever met who whose
beard is is is bigger than then the
person the beard is growing upon yeah so
yeah to me Patrick Rothfuss his beard
wins going up he's also just a lovely
lovely person just to haven't met a
nicer person and wouldn't be nicer just
so nice I mean either he's like
incredibly supportive and nice and
empathetic but also doesn't take any of
your crap like he's amazing he's you
know I think sometimes you meet people
and you don't know them well but you
like meet them and and you're like I
look forward to seeing that person again
so much you have friends who maybe like
aren't your closest friends but you
just you love seeing them yeah he's one
of those people yeah we're working on a
conference together so we're talking a
lot right now which is nice to get it to
be on the phone once a week or so and
and it's called nerdcon stories and
tickets are available now the agenda
went live earlier last week I guess and
it's gonna be fascinating
it's a Minneapolis and if you were
around there or even if you just want to
come see a lot of amazing storytellers
authors poets musicians that sort of
thing then did come on come on over John
and I will be there it's gonna be a good
time I will be there it's my only public
appearance for the next year actually
also Hank I don't know if you know this
but are you aware of what Maggie Steve
Vader it's the voters eve steve fader
yeah you know Maggie are you aware of
what Maggie and I are doing uh I heard I
heard a rumor but I don't know I don't
know if it's three are racing each other
in an actual car race with actual race
cars on a dirt track a half mile dirt
track outside of Minneapolis that Friday
night so in addition to going to nerdcon
stories you can go and watch an
extremely successful young adult
novelist who is also a race car driver
race me a person who has not gotten in a
car crash in a couple of years I didn't
know about that I heard something about
that I assume that was remote-control
cars it's one of those things where like
Maggie was like would you want to do
this and I was like yeah of course that
sounds hilarious and then but you know
like I I didn't think she would actually
set it up and and then she's like asking
me how the circumference of my head so I
can get a helmet that's the right size
and I got to wear a fire suit in case
the race car catches on fire and I'm
just thinking like I've got a I've got a
not get lapped that's my goal
just want to not get lapped so that's
Friday night and then Saturday and
Sunday is nerdcon stories it's gonna be
an amazing weekend this one's from
Natalie who says dear Hank and John my
name is Natalie and I'm not thinking
about applying to college in the US
but I have absolutely no confidence in
my speaking and pronunciation ability
since I'm from Ecuador and I speak
Spanish as my native language do you
have any advice for improving my
speaking yes I do let's come up with a
hashtag on Twitter for talk to Natalie
and maybe you can find some people who
speak English natively to talk to you
what should that hashtag be John hashtag
talk talk to Natalie
so if English is your first language you
just use the hashtag talk to Natalie and
then maybe Natalie will find out about
this and then she can talk to you but in
general Natalie I have to say I think
you're gonna be fine having read your
email which was grammatically perfect
which is extremely rare for dear Hank
and John emails I think you're I think
you're in good shape yeah absolutely yes
all right that one was easy Hank I'm
gonna ask a question that's somewhat
harder now this one is from Isabella who
asks what do you do when your parents
have a different political opinion than
yours and they try to force theirs upon
you oh man John and I don't don't know
because like the like the only way that
this has happened to us well it's
happened to me a bit with my in-laws
though they are very nice about it but
with our parents it's like we like how
far left can you go is is often the
topic at our dinner table yeah I mean I
guess that we I I do have some different
political yes beliefs than my parents
but but but first like they don't try to
enforce their beliefs on me and they
really never have even when we were
little kids it's true you know when I
when I was like nine years old and I
said that I thought Ronald Reagan should
be elected president and not Walter
Mondale my dad was incredibly supportive
in fact I didn't even know at the time
that you know he'd secretly written me
out of his will but no I mean you know
yeah our parents are extremely I mean I
wouldn't say that they're communist but
I would definitely say that they are
further to the left than either Hank or
I and Hank and I are pretty pretty
aggressive liberal on the political
spectrum I don't know actually I'm not
I'm not as liberal as Hank the order is
my mother my father
and then me almost in the center in some
northern European nations Hank I would
be a centrist oh gosh and some northern
European nations you would be you would
be to the right I might be actually so
Mike I have a good friend who is a
Jesuit priest he is a Catholic priest
and he and his parents often have
political disagreements and he has been
a real model for me and like how to talk
about politics or other controversial
topics with people who disagree with you
and it seems to me that what he does
very well is is listen he listens very
well and very openly and he he tries to
understand people's concerns who
disagree with him and then he states why
he believes what he believes you know
very strongly and clearly and and he
doesn't apologize for it but he's also
not aggressive about it he doesn't
assume that people who disagree with him
are evil he just you know like has XY
and Z justifications for his belief
system and I also of course often
disagree with him as well although my
disagreements with him are different
than his family's disagreements with him
and I find it really kind of
invigorating and refreshing to be able
to have conversations with him because
they aren't confrontational and they it
doesn't feel dichotomous it doesn't feel
like there's good and evil and I am
always on the side of good and those who
disagree with me are always on the side
of evil it's just really really hard in
contemporary American political
discourse to have those kinds of
conversations to embrace subtlety and
nuance and also to acknowledge the
possibility that you might be wrong
which you might be I mean as strong as
my convictions are I might be wrong I've
been wrong before that what your friend
does and and what you know I think we
should all attempt to do is really hard
it requires great presence of mind and
also great sort of understanding of your
own perspectives and biases
and it is important and such an amazing
exercise in like in in knowing yourself
and understanding understanding you know
where like who like how you became who
you are that's difficult thing but if
you can do it even if you can just try
to do it it's it has dividends that are
way outside of like improving your
ability to discuss politics with your
parents because it it helps you know
yourself and it helps you you know
better understand not only where your
opinions come from but why other people
think the way they do and that's it's
hard but it is a really powerful ability
to cultivate yeah I mean I don't want to
pretend that it's not hard though
because I think on a day-to-day
minute-to-minute basis it's often
impossible not to feel outraged
particularly when people are you know
expressing outrage at you it's very
difficult not to respond to that by
getting ratcheted up and like you know
getting angry and it's it's hard and I
feel like I mean I think it's always
been hard but I certainly feel like the
the way that political discourse has
become so so black and white that there
are these two political positions in
America one of quote-unquote liberalism
and one of quote-unquote conservatism
has not helped our ability to have
conversations because you were expected
to be either one thing or another and
then you you kind of don't end up having
conversations about policy and that's
the other thing I'd say is that I find
it much more interesting and I find it
much more interesting and helpful to
have conversations about policy like
instead of saying should we tax the rich
like let's ask well what should the
income tax rate on income over five
hundred thousand dollars a year be you
know should it be 34% should it be 37%
that becomes a question about policy and
about nuance not a question about like
the government is trying to take from
successful people versus the rich have
to do their part
I find questions about like specific
policy considerations much more
beneficial to me
and that being said there's a complete
possibility that your parents are just
really mad and upset and scared about
the state of the world and they think
that things are going very badly and
that makes them reactionary and upset
and and and it's you know that it's fear
that's driving that you know that
outrage usually and you know personal
fear but also fear that things are just
going places where they shouldn't go and
you know sometimes when I'm dealing with
scared people what I after what I do is
just sort of like acknowledge their fear
and not engage with it because like what
are you gonna do say you don't have the
right to be afraid their fear might come
from bad places therefore you might come
from unconscious bias their fear might
come from you know just being exposed to
people who are intentionally trying to
scare them all the time but there's not
a lot you can do about that yeah yeah I
totally agree with you let's move on to
the next question
Hank our next question comes from Emily
who writes dear John and Hank I've been
having trouble falling asleep lately
particularly because I want to hum and
sing songs I get stuck in my head do you
have any advice on how to get the song
out of my head so I can get to sleep
thank you for your dubious advice and
don't forget it's a comedy podcast Oh
Emily I have already forgotten that it's
a comedy podcast because all I see in
front of me is the gaping canyon that is
the endless misery of being unable to
sleep until finally at last death comes
for you and you can do nothing but sleep
oh I have a higher a sort of surface
level question here is it possible that
you a person who's having trouble
sleeping and is singing all the time
have a roommate who might think that you
are really messy Emily I just need you
to double-check that you are paying your
bills on time and not really messy
because I think the underlying problem
could potentially be that you know
you're having a difficult time with with
the unemployment into everything but
you're a different person then then yeah
I think we need to look at different
different possible solutions here my
number one go-to solution for an earworm
which is a song stuck in your head is
free fallin by Tom Petty once I just
start singing free fallin whatever was
in my head goes away and I can just
drift off to sleep free fallin I I have
no ability to help you because I sleep
really well because I take medicines
that make me very tired so you could
take Murr captive hearing and that works
for me it's it's it's not it's not
without its side-effects it is not
intended to be a sleepy drug but it sure
does knock me out yeah Emily go ahead
and get all sort of colitis so you can
take the pill that Hank takes to make
him sleepy it's worth it
you know Hank when Sara and I first
started dating like we would you know
like well hmm you know when we first
Hank when Sara and I got married and
began to sleep in in the same bed for
the first time in our entire
relationship he would she would often
sort of be chatting with me toward the
end of the evening and I would be
talking back to her and we'd and I'd be
talking about something and then I would
look over and I would learn that she was
asleep and in fact in the 11 or 12 years
that we've been a going concern I've
never seen her take more than 12 seconds
to fall asleep it is the most
infuriating thing about my wife the idea
that you can lay your head upon a pillow
and fall asleep at the time of your
choosing is so foreign to me and I am so
intensely jealous of it I can't even
explain it to you
so Emily I do empathize my number one
piece of advice when it comes to
sleeping is is to spend at least 30
minutes away from screens before you try
to go to sleep yeah and the another
important one is to is to have a really
set schedule of sleep which is very hard
to do but that's what the sleep
scientists say the number
thing for insomnia is going to sleep and
waking up at the roughly the same time
every day and who does that though
really but you know the other thing Hank
I can't help but recommend as a solution
to this this humming business maybe
listening to you know that the sweet
sweet baritone of a podcast before you
go to bed like for instance maybe re
listen to old episodes of Dear John and
Hank that's a good idea
we're too engaging John fades episode of
dear Hank and John is brought to you by
dear Hank and John itself that's right
we're sponsored by recursion man listen
to dear Hank and John it's available on
iTunes or wherever podcasts are free
today's episode of dear Hank and John is
of course also brought to you by nerdcon
stores nerdcon stories october
minneapolis racecars stories today's
episode of dear Hank and John is brought
to you by Patrick Rothfuss beard which
is epic and glorious and historically
significant and would totally win over
john green's puffs in a fight today's
episode of dear Hank and John is brought
to you by Taylor Swift Taylor Swift the
most important country and pop musician
of the last 15 years Taylor Swift on
tour now ahh
to know I'd go see her if she came to
Missoula Montana I'll tell you what um
well she isn't because I have all of her
tour stops memorized ah yeah I don't
know that she would find a room that
could be really suitable though we do
have a stadium she could she could just
play at the stadium some people do that
The Rolling Stones played we had the
Rolling Stones John we're a big
metropolis now we had the Rolling Stones
play at the Indianapolis Motor Speedway
on July 4th it was magical I was not
actually in town because I was touring
for Paper Towns but I heard that it went
well speaking of which we have a
question from Robert Robert writes dear
John and Hank John has written in the
past about the do's and don'ts of
meeting him or any well-known person as
a fan my question is what are the do's
and don'ts of conducting a press junket
to interview oh my there are lots of
ways it can go wrong but what can make
it go really well ah well I've not done
I've done a couple of press junket
interviews but John has done a million
of them literally also
an added question to this is how can
John green not embarrass himself when
meeting Taylor Swift so let's let's do
let's do Roberts question first
Hank talk to me about what kind of fan
interaction works for you like if you're
in Target and you're meeting Taylor
Swift what what no that's not no like if
you're in Target and someone comes up to
you and says hi like what's the ideal
way it could go um it I mean there's
there's multiple ideal ways like some
people would just be like hey thanks for
the videos that helped me with biology
which is great like I like that a lot
because then I feel like I approved like
it it was it's it's immediately obvious
the value I provided whereas you know I
also like it when it's more sort of
obscure and like oh my gosh that's you
I'd like all of your things you do so
many things and I like all of them
that's also nice I just it's to me that
as long as you're not expecting me to do
something like to like be you know like
funny or like to make make like do some
kind of performance then I'm happy I'm
happy to take a picture I'm happy to
talk I'm happy to you know like you know
I'm happy to be complimented in public
by a stranger but but there are having a
couple of times where it's it's been
like it's it felt like this person is
disappointed that I am NOT not doing
like a thing and I'm like well I'm
currently just just here to buy my to
get my suppositories from the pharmacy
so yeah I mean I would say 99% of the
time I've been approached by fans it's
been awesome like it it's it is really
encouraging to hear from people to get
to hear from people directly you know
what kind of stuff that you make matters
to them and how it matters to them and
that varies from like the person at
Target who pointed at me and said crash
course world history and gave me a fist
bump and kept walking you know to people
who come up and tell me that they're
nerdfighters and and what you know the
nerdfighter community means to them and
and that it gives me a chance to to talk
about how
it means to me so that's that's really
lovely and I think like that's the
perfect thing and that's what I'm gonna
try to do if I do meet Taylor Swift I'm
just gonna say you know I really love
your work and I when when we were on the
set of the Paper Towns movie it was it
was long days and a lot of hard days for
me and I listened to 1989 every day and
it was like the soundtrack of that part
of my life and I'll always have
wonderful memories because of it
not that I've practiced what I'm gonna
say but as far as as far as press junket
interviews go I mean I I don't nobody
likes press junket so the press doesn't
like them the the people who are doing
them don't like them I think the people
at the studio who organized them don't
like them I think that the people who
are running the cameras and the mics
don't like them I don't think it's fun
for anyone I think it's it's considered
sort of a necessary evil to try to get
get the word out about the the movie or
whatever the project is I I guess I
guess the only thing I would say is is
to try to remember that the people that
you're talking to have been talking to
people all day and that they've had a
different interview every six minutes
and that they are feeling probably
pretty dehumanized and pretty exhausted
when I was on the fresh junket for Paper
Towns a hippopotamus escaped a zoo in
Budapest I think and every between every
interview not wolf would just show me a
picture of this escaped hippopotamus and
he would whisper someday that will be us
and I found it tremendously comforting
to think of the escaped hippopotamus and
on multiple occasions people would like
test how well NAT and I knew each other
and and one of the questions would
always be do like what's your favorite
animal or what's John's favorite animal
or whatever and it would we would be so
specific we would write hippopotamus
recently escaped from Zoo in Budapest
yeah I mean the only thing I would say
is is you know if you have to get the
quotes that you have to get then like go
in and ask the questions that you have
to ask and I guess probably don't have a
particularly high set of expectations
for what people are going to say because
I think it's almost impossible
to answer a question thoughtfully when
you're so tired and feel so weird and
yeah but if you want to try to have a
look like a really interesting thing
then just do something that's completely
different where you don't ask any of
those questions and you just maybe allow
them to play a game like I remember when
I was in Brazil a reporter played a game
with us where she was like NAT you and I
are going to create a new John Green
novel together and John you are going to
provide the dialogue and that was really
like a really fun seven minutes in fact
at the end of it NAT was like can we
please just keep doing this and stop the
other so I don't know it's not easy and
like I think it's kind of inherently
dehumanizing it's really difficult in
those situations for the people who are
being interviewed to remember that the
interviewer you know is a person who is
having a very specific seven minutes of
their day and it's really difficult for
the interviewer to think that about the
people who are being interviewed so my
strategy moving forward is going to be
trying to avoid them as much as possible
alright John it seems like it might be
time for the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon the ideas Hank I think it is
time what's the news from Mars this week
well in Mars news on the that I think
The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon no it
was with Stephen Colbert the new the new
Colbert show which I don't know what
that's called it's very confusing
because they all sound exactly the same
to me
did he not change his name to Kolbert
now is he still Cobain I would assume
that he still I thought Colbert was just
the just the the act but I guess that
his real name that's his real name
okay nice guy by the way yeah he seems
like a great guy I know but I've hung
out with him oh right you did yeah yeah
I have not I just hung out with a
president so that was a total brag I
apologize I want to apologize to my
friends and family for that clear
unadulterated brag that's fine
no nothing bragging well Elon Musk was
on on Stephen Colbert's show and they
were talking about Mars Mars came up I I
hate I hate to bring this up but I've
also hung out with you on Musk
did you did you get to go to the White
House and and hang out with the
president job
no no but only because I was like I
think my brother should do that he
hasn't had a big big media here in a
while
uh-huh yep that's that's see that's that
sense how I remember yes all right I'm
sorry
what did my friend Eli talk about with
my friend Stephen Colbert they were
talking about Mars and how how to
potentially make Mars habitable or more
habitable for future visitors and Elon
Musk proposed the fast way to make Mars
a little warmer and give it some
atmosphere would just be to drop a bunch
of thermonuclear bombs on the poles of
the planet which what yeah so Elon Musk
you know noted Tony Stark impersonator
creator of many amazing things including
PayPal which no one talks about and and
Tesla Motors and SpaceX has proposed
that we drop H bombs on the poles of
Mars so that the silicate carbon dioxide
and water and that it's stored in the
poles of Mars would be released to the
atmosphere then there would be a quote
runaway greenhouse effect which would
warm the planet further which would
create more carbon dioxide and water
being released into the atmosphere which
would warm the planet further etc this
is a legitimate idea there are a couple
of problems with it one if there is an
ecology on Mars it would be the largest
scientific discovery in the history of
mankind and we don't want to just really
mess up that ecology really fast before
we study it - you're dumping a bunch of
thermonuclear weapons on Mars which
might be you know there are ways to
design nuclear weapons so like
particularly fusion bombs so that they
have less fallout but they're still
going to be some fallout that's not
ideal and of course you are just
releasing carbon dioxide and water into
the atmosphere which is not the kind of
atmosphere that humans would really
enjoy breathing but it would help shield
astronauts from radiation and it would
it would increase the pressure
of the planet which is good because it
would mean you know less vacuum to
immediately kill people at who were on
the surface it does not solve a lot of
the problems that Mars has with regards
to habitability but it's not that far
out there idea you know it's certainly
not within the next hundred years though
yes now as you know I'm not a expert in
science or in Mars or anything but what
what would if we did that what would
happen to the dinosaurs on Mars
well the dinosaurs that are on Mars in
our and erratic more movie Jurassic Mars
would would have to be specially
designed to to function in that
atmosphere whatever that atmosphere is
which it doesn't see it like that
doesn't seem outside of the realm of of
movie science which is completely fake
anyway so let's just design dinosaurs
that can breathe water vapor instead of
oxygen which of course chemically makes
no sense but who cares and and we'll be
fine
Jurassic Mars coming to theaters so it
has not affected the box-office
potential of Jurassic Mars
not at all III think that introducing
the possibility of thermonuclear
warheads into Jurassic that the plot of
Jurassic Mars can only be a positive I
actually completely agree with you
because whether it's at the beginning of
act 1 or the end of act 2 there is
definitely an opportunity for nuclear
war on Jurassic Mars so Hank I don't
know how much you know about the history
of AFC Wimbledon but you're about to
know a little bit more as you do know
back in 2001 the club was moved by
rapacious owners to the town of Milton
Keynes a hundred miles away from
Wimbledon the historic home of this
football club that had been together for
120 years and then Wimbledon supporters
in protest started their own Club AFC
Wimbledon but they couldn't start at the
historic home of Wimbledon which is
actually you know in Merton this stadium
called plough Lane
so in fact on the closed sad gates of
plough Lane at the very end of its
history before
it was destroyed in the early 2000s
someone spray-painted womble till I died
because the Womble is the mascot of AFC
Wimbledon and in fans are often called
Wombles and and so now they play their
games in in Kingston at a in South
London at a stadium that also houses a
non-league side called Kingstonian but
the dream has always been to get back to
plough Lane in fact AFC Wimbledon fans
sing a song show me the way to plough
Lane the dream has always been to get
back to the historic spiritual home of
this Football Club with a new stadium
that can support permanently you know a
club of AFC Wimbledon size and maybe
even allow them to make more money and
and have you know more concession sales
and stuff so they can maybe get up to
Ligue 1 or even higher and so they're
trying to build this 11,000 seat stadium
that's directly across the street from
where plough Lane was plough Lane is now
houses and it's been a long effort it's
it's really beginning to take shape now
and as part of that they're selling
Kingsmeadow their current stadium to
Chelsea Football Club one of my least
favorite possibly my least favorite
football club owned by Roman Abramovich
who bought the the club Chelsea
literally with the blood of Russian
peasants he just sent a large amount of
Russian peasant blood to London and then
was given Chelsea Football Club
so anyway Chelsea it looks like is gonna
buy Kingsmeadow to help fund the
building of the new AFC Wimbledon
Stadium and this is great news because
for the club to really really exist long
term they need a stadium they need a
place of their own that's in the
community of of the football club and
this is a huge huge deal to Wimbledon
fans I mean for instance Hank MK Dons
fans you know the team that that
Wimbledon that that stole Wimbledon away
and and made it their new team in Milton
Keynes you know them sure yep
they sing to make fun of AFC Wimbledon
they sing you're just a pub team from
Kingston to say like you're not really
Wimbledon and you're not really a club
you're just a pub team from Kingston to
be able to be back in Wimbledon in a
stadium that's appropriate for a
football league club really would be the
end of this story and and would put the
club on a stable path where they can
really they can survive and so it's a
huge deal to be selling Kingsmeadow to
help fund the building of the new
stadium but there's still a long way to
go and if you're a member of the dons
trust which Hank by the way you are I
just bought you a membership you own
exactly as much AFC Wimbledon as I do or
as the chairman of the club Eric
Samuelson does all 5500 of us he owned
equal shares of Wimbledon happy birthday
now if you're a member of AFC Wimbledon
you you can vote in fact you need to
vote if you remember the Dons trust you
need to vote to help move this forward
to sell the current stadium and then to
invest to buy and build the new stadium
it's a really really exciting time in
the club's history and really for the
first time you know in the last 10 years
it looks like the stadium might might
actually happen that's great what's
gonna happen to the current stadium the
Chelsea owns it though oh yeah so
Chelsea is going to turn it into a place
for their women's team and also their
youth teams how come so they'll play
their games there and it'll be good for
the development of their women's side
and and they're like under under 18 side
so it's great for them to potentially
anyway because Chelsea need a better
developed women's soccer program as I've
talked about previously in the podcast
AFC Wimbledon has a really strong
women's soccer program but many teams in
the Football League including very
famous ones don't like Manchester United
doesn't have a women's soccer team at
all which is just an embarrassment and
so it's great I think it's great
potentially great for everyone but the
main thing from from Wimbledon's
perspective is you know gosh how amazing
would it be to have an 11,000 seat brand
new state-of-the-art Stadium
you know where they could play and and
grow into being being the the club that
that they could be if they just didn't
have this very small Stadium cool
that's exciting John I'm so excited I
can't even tell you I can't wait to go
Hank we're gonna do so many crazy
sponsorships of the new stadium I'm
gonna get so many like bricks on the on
the walkway to the new stadium dedicated
to you I'll be like this is the Hank
green Mars sucks brick this is the
fourth Rock from the Sun who cares brick
this is the AFC Wimbledon is more
important than Mars brick I'm gonna buy
you so many anti Mars bricks at the new
stadium all right thanks I your jerk
what did we learn today Hank oh we
learned that you can never really know
why your roommates being a bad roommate
so you need to talk about it and of
course we learned that the key to taking
Jurassic Mars to the next level is
thermonuclear warfare
we learned that a podcast can sponsor
itself and we learned that if a song
free fall and by Tom Petty wasn't in
your head
it is now Hank thank you so much for
podcasting with me this is my favorite
part of the week and I also I also want
to thank everybody for listening their
comments and responses on Twitter I
still check my @replies even though I'm
not tweeting I really do mean a lot to
me so thank you guys for listening and
we hope that you continue to enjoy the
podcast yeah if you could hashtag your
things on Twitter hashtag dear Hank and
John so that we know that those things
are there don't use hashtag Dear John
and Hank that would be confusing the
show's called dear Hank why don't they
just use hashtag talk to Natalie and
that way Natalie can also have more
people to get in touch with well I think
that if they have specific questions
with regard to dear Hank and John they
want to correct us on something in fact
we do have a correction which is that I
said that the number one impact that you
can have on the world is by controlling
how much you heat or don't heat your
place of dwelling but in fact I was
corrected the number one impact you can
have is eating less meat
which there's a tremendous amount of
greenhouse gases that are produced in
the production of meat especially the
large animal meats of of pork and beef
so that is the thing that you can also
do and and has a tremendous impact so
Corrections such as those or or just
comments so that we can see what people
are thinking
you can hashtag Dear John and ha dear
Hank of John a hashtag dear Hank of John
I prefer the hashtag Dear John and Hank
myself but I guess it's up to readers
listeners whatever they call themselves
it's font used to your Hank and John
that's fine today's podcast was edited
by our friend Nick yeah if they're the
theme music is from gunnarolla you can
send us questions at Hank and John at
gmail.com and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]